our kitchen designs are so drastically
different and we're really struggling to
meet them in the middle let's call
Connie I'm here hi Connie you guys
a lot of things that
things that you have in common even
though it may not feel like it symbolic
Beach I guess more than the literal
Beach let's get designing
[Music]
between our Aesthetics and we finally
brought our Sims kitchen design to life
are you guys ready to see
it's our Dream kitchen that we built
using our designs from The Sims don't
you love it absolutely love it it looks
so good can you even believe that we
were able to take our two super
different designs and make them one
truthfully no but I'm very happy with
the results and there's a couple of
design elements that we really feel tie
in both of our Styles I would say
incorporate things like teals and stuff
like that that still has that almost
like darker kind of aesthetic and Vibe
but it also has like the bright fun pop
of colors all right I'm sure you guys
see it behind me but this tile
backsplash it has a little bit of like a
mermaid Vibe it has a pop of color but
exactly like Connie was talking about
adding these elements of like ocean and
beachiness without it being too on the
nose so you just get like the vibe of it
I actually do like that color a lot of
scholar so we were able to find a couple
of cool ways of showing that the kitchen
is lived in without being messy we were
able to have these jar cars out show
some of our favorite Pantry items while
kind of using them as Decor as well if
you have anything that's like not so
cute to look at you can stick it in a
Cupboard and call it a day we had so
many overlapping elements in our Sims
design we had to add these as Easter
eggs throughout our kitchen design here
I'm really happy because my number one
concern was having some dark elements in
the kitchen that I got what I wanted we
have the really cool black pendant
lighting which I think was a cool way to
incorporate something dark with
literally something light we also have
the dark countertops which I love
especially with like the leather teal
that you chose it makes it pop
absolutely I actually really like the
black countertops I think they are cool
contrast against all the other colors
it's still cool because I was able to
add other wood elements which I really
love and add to this kind of like
naturey aspect so we got like the Oaky
wood on this table it just adds a little
more lightness to it it's not too like
beachy mermaid it's like edgy beachy
mermaid like if the beachy mermaid lived
in Silver Lake
another thing that we both agreed on was
plants and more specifically live and
we've got a bunch but who's gonna water
them I will water it yeah don't worry
plants offer the opportunity to get some
cool vases as well so we have some Cool
Pops of color and then of course we have
our gnome don't forget most important we
can't forget that let's never forget no
we did have a great opportunity for our
wine storage up top and not only does it
help keep a really clean and organized
kitchen but it's also really pretty to
display who doesn't love one
unfortunately no hot tub though we have
a little something for you in the fridge
oh haha
yes
oh my God
scuba diving I think this really closes
out our amazing dream kitchen that we
designed in The Sims and now we have
everything we need oh I feel so relieved
we did it our kitchen looks amazing and
we really were able to find a middle
ground between both of our design
Aesthetics we were I was I was wrong say
it again
now we feel even more in love and
compatible
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
okay can you guys find all the Easter
eggs that we added from our Sims kitchen
design in this kitchen comment down
below
[Music]